way
[Music]
over the rainbow we love
[Music]
I know at one point Judy was called the
greatest performer of her generation of
greatest performer alive and Judy has
this great sense of humor in the film
and you say why is Frank Sinatra here
who do you think is the greatest
performer now oh that's good that's a
really good question
well there's Beyonce yeah so funny
that's what Finn said yeah she just
she's in full fully accesses her power
at every turn yeah
unapologetically creatively she's in
charge yeah it's a wonderful thing to
see so I'm wondering for you there was
what I loved is there was live
performances in this movie I was
wondering for you how old you were the
first time you sang a Judy song out loud
and compare it to singing live in this
film sort of juxtaposed for me was it in
your bedroom with a hairbrush or well
I'm sure that rainbow was in the
repertoire cuz you know I'm of the
generation where you had to be home to
see it and every year it was on TV
okay it's on you know you're running
come back the commercials over you know
and my brother you know shut up so I I
was always singing and he was always
asking me not to so yeah I can't
remember a specific time but it's always
been in there yeah and then versus
singing what was it like for you because
it you appeared to me to be possessed by
this character I mean just there were so
many beautiful close-up shots and it was
really it the singing was amazing but it
was in the eyes that really got me so
what was that moment like for you oh
gosh I don't know I don't know I just uh
I don't know um just collecting
information all the time and you know
listening to audio of her voice and
looking at videos when I was going to
sleep at night and
and never being away from it ever yeah
just you know yeah I just I don't know
just felt like a celebration and I
wanted to you know yeah so knowing that
and knowing that you studied her for two
years and watched things before you went
to bed and tried to extract every nugget
I was wondering for you cuz when I was
watching your performance I was thinking
to myself that looks like it was
exhausting like you probably what was it
like for you when you shot your last
scene you woke up the next day and you
weren't gonna play her anymore what was
that sort of period like do you know
it's funny we didn't have that because
we finished and it was on to the next
thing
okay now we're gonna record the
orchestra live and so come on we're
gonna do the recordings with the
orchestra life for you know soundtrack
and then okay we're gonna do this other
thing now and it just kept going until
like last month
Wow and now you're gonna be talking
about it for first several months do you
have any Judy memorabilia yes I do I do
I have a couple of the play books from
her shows which are very special and
some photographs did you have it before
signing on to this project or was it as
a result of doing the film as a result
yeah I'm not a big collector of anything
actually so yes these were these sort of
treats so I know everybody's talking
about this performance how do you feel
when you watch it I haven't seen it I
saw a really early cut I haven't seen it
finished yet I might watch it this week
I don't know I kind of loved how I
remember it
the experience of making it is that in
general for you you just usually yeah
yes because it's you know that's real
that's your shared collaborations with
these you know a group of people who
become your friends and and that's
that's what it is to me in my life
tonight and we all had the the same
motivation for wanting to make it you
know we all feel affection in a
connection to her in some way in an
appreciation for her and everybody
wanted to celebrate her and that's what
it felt like and that's what it feels
launching that's oh thank you I know
you're her kids you didn't talk to her
kids
but you said if there was something you
could have asked them you would have
asked what they wanted to see on screen
yeah what do you hope people will get
and see on screen turning the question
on you um context yeah because it's
impossible to look at her life in this
period of her life as tragic when you
better understand what led to the
circumstances and when you see what it
is that she was able to overcome in
order to continue to deliver and connect
with her audiences in the way that just
moved people for generations that then
you it sets her apart you can really see
how extraordinary she was what room
service I didn't order anything
doesn't matter under the Train surprise
I can't miss you and they also want to
stay both and coming back father
you're not listening that's someone I
can rely on you
[Music]
Salwa you have to be home for your mommy
to put you to bed there's been so much
talk about on set sort of like watching
Renee she was like possessed by Judy
yeah being there in that moment when she
was singing live because that was one of
the beautiful things about this film is
she was singing live can you sort of
describe it because when they pan to a
close-up you see it in her eyes but
being there amongst the audience I'll
tell you that the extras that were there
that playing the audience all all stood
up every take stood up and applauded
like they weren't supposed to sound guy
was like quiet please who to capture
this quiet but it was um it was
genuinely riveting and it's rare to see
someone who who can like judy did like
be that subtle and you know can can fill
a close-up but can also fill a big
theatre yeah and and be riveting an
alive theatre experience which she read
akin to what was for you I mean you play
her last husband in her life and there's
I can't really figure him out
and you kind of can't figure in my own
movie like what is his motive what is he
no one can figure him out did you figure
him out how much how much were you able
to delve into when was there like a fun
little nugget that you found sort of
digging through I
I found the he wrote a book which was
really interesting and in it he they
would have big blowout fights but at the
end like after this movie ends they date
they got a house in London and they they
kind of lived there till she till she
died he found her yeah he did actually
find her he says he found her overdosed
in the bathroom so like that knowing
that it ended happier than we ended like
was good for my mind that like this he
wasn't just for himself like he he was
maybe he you know complicated and itself
with all the points but he was genuinely
I think devoted to her and and was kind
of a caretaker at a time when she was
really needing that and was kind of
flailing and had been kind of chewed up
by the system and so I think the fact
that he was not a movie star that he was
kind of outside of it
but was kind of a pretty reliable person
and it was also like youthful and fun
and you know I think that they had a
good time together and I got to jump out
of a room service tray oh yeah other
husbands could do that
so she um Judy Garland was once called I
think it was by Mickey Rooney the
greatest performer alive yeah in your
opinion today who's the greatest
performer a lot oh that's tough
ah that's tough i-i-i i don't know i
mean i-i think the difference is i I can
I can point to like great musical
performers I've seen I was Beyonce I saw
pretty freaking cool but but like the
Judy could do that she could like
basically be Beyonce live but then she
could like also be like you know Cate
Blanchett on screen you know that she
was able to do both things it's pretty
rare you know
yeah what about an actor uh you know I
saw Bryan Cranston onstage in this show
Network and he was able to that there
was a lot of the show that was like a
projection of his close-up of his face
as he was talking to the audience and so
he was able to act for a close-up and
for Broadway theatre and that I don't
know how you do that that's pretty cool
you